une question aussi du paiement mensuel
de l'impôt pour moi cette mesure est
bien parce que au fur à mesure que le
poids de l'impôt augmente en raison de
la progression des revenus car
heureusement les revenus reine des
français augmente les charges de
trésorerie de la tow pourra particuliers
deviennent des charges très lourdes il a
payé soudas au 4 septembre des sommes
qu'ils représentent pour lui plus d'un
mois très fréquemment de son traitement
de son salaire donc une difficulté très
au fait alors tout le pays comparables
c'est-à-dire dalmat les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne
notre technique qui consiste à retenir
mensuellement une partie de la de
l'impôt une sorte d'accord nous n'avons
pas choisi le système parce qu'il est en
france une certaine prévention contre le
paiement mensuel de l'impôt bhl cela
peut être ou la technique de la retenue
à la source ou au contraire la technique
du paiement mensuel volontaire de
l'impôt confiée à un organisme qui peut
être son employeur peut être une banque
qui met les chèques postaux le soin de
payer pour vous mois par mois mais
voulait seriez le choix aux français ce
qu'ils voudraient payer d'impôts alors
nous allons nous faisons actuellement
une étude tous les systèmes qui existent
nous allons établir un livre blanc d'ici
la fin de l'année nous soumettrons ce
livre blanc à l'ensemble des
organisations professionnelles et
syndicales et en particulier aux cadres
qui sont particulièrement attentifs cet
aspect des choses
[Musique]